كانت رئتي هي رئتي طفل يبلغ من العمر سبع سنوات ،
بدأ آدم هيرغ إنريكير التدخين الإلكتروني عندما
كان يبلغ من العمر 16 عامًا ونصف بعد ذلك ،
هبط في وحدة العناية المركزة ، حيث
قال طبيبه بسبب استخدام الـفيبينج Vaping ، كان لدي
رعشات فيه ولم أستطع  السيطرة عليه ،
لذلك كنت أركض في
التشنج وكان مخيفًا حقًا أنني عرفت أنه لم يكن
سكتة دماغية ولكن شعرت بهذا لأنني
لم أستطع السيطرة على نفسي في
البداية اعتقد آدم أنها
أنفلونزا المعدة ولكن بعد أيام من الغثيان
والقيء  انتهى الأمر بمركز كانديل الطبي
في ليبرتيفيل إلينوي ليعرف
أن رئتي ابني يبلغ من العمر 18 عامًا بصحة جيدة ،
وهو رياضي نموذجي يبلغ من العمر 18 عامًا
يستلقي في سرير ولا يكون قادرًا على
التنفس ، وهو كابوس كل
أبوين بدأ آدم في التدخين الإلكتروني.
النيكوتين ثم انتقل إلى الماريجوانا ،
لذلك بدأت في استخدام الـ vaping لأول مرة فقط
لأن الجميع كان يفعل ذلك
بحلول الوقت الذي وصل فيه إلى المستشفى كان
مريضًا بشدة إذا لم تحضره
والدته إلى المستشفى خلال اليومين
التاليين  ثلاثة أيام من الممكن أن
يتفاقم تنفسه لدرجة أنه كان من الممكن أن
يموت إذا لم يطلب الرعاية الطبية. آدم
هو واحد من أكثر من 450 حالة محتملة
من الأمراض المرتبطة بالتبخير الإلكتروني في جميع أنحاء
البلاد وفقًا لمركز السيطرة على الأمراض ، لكن آدم هو
أيضًا واحد من  من المحظوظين ،
حدثت ست وفيات في ولاية كاليفورنيا ،
إلينوي ، إنديانا ، مينيسوتا ، أوريغون
وكانساس ، وأكبر لغز لا
يعرفه أحد بالضبط ما هي المكونات الموجودة في كل
سيجارة التي تسبب المشاكل ، يمكنك
أن ترى التعتيم الأبيض الضبابي في
جميع أنحاء رئتيه على كلا الجانبين ، لذلك
على الرغم من أننا لا نفعل ذلك.  لا أعرف على
وجه اليقين الطبيعة الدقيقة لما يسبب
التعتيم الذي يُفترض أنه مرتبط
بتدخين السجائر الإلكترونية الخاصة به حتى يكتشفوا الأمر
ويقول مسؤولو الصحة العامة إنه لا يجب استخدام الـ vaping.